corrosive
catastrophic people feel what he is now
and often covertly monopoly
corruption costs the world nearly three
trillion dollars every year
and blights the lives of hundreds of
millions
but in some parts of the world there's a
renewed drive
to disrupt corruption we need to act
with
urgency and purpose to restore
our state-owned enterprises from bold
moves at the top
we've got to make sure that there's
strong committed ethical leadership
to new technologies shining a light on
the problem
now in ukraine we have the most
transparent corruption
in the world communities companies and
countries
are learning lessons in how to root out
corruption
our country changed to one of the
obvious technological
leaders hold the guilty to account this
was one of the largest cases the sfo had
worked on
and challenge the culture that allows it
to continue
do we accept the way it is or do you
stand up for something
[Applause]
this is a notoriously violent and
lawless district of cape town in south
africa
here in cape flats there were almost a
thousand murders in the first six months
of 2019
and police corruption is helping to fuel
this violence
our quarter was a year old year so we
decided to give him a little
party
he grew up in the community as a
teenager
he got married one kid
and then in 2015 he was murdered
avril andrews says both she and the
police
know the identity of the killer who shot
her son
alcardo dead
but avril believes police corruption has
stalled her search for justice
corruption affects our community very
much i've experienced it myself in
police even with the recent case
one of the guys tried to intimidate my
family
our community is going down you know
people feel there's no hope
since her son's death avril has spoken
out publicly
at great personal risk against the
corrupt forces
undermining the rule of law in her
community
el cado this is the fourth year that
we are seeking justice
there are certain things that you've
discussed with me
that you would have loved to do in the
community
so i'm doing it for you i believe we're
going to get justice
in south africa the police are known to
supply weapons to gangs
in 2016 a former police colonel pleaded
guilty to illegally selling 2
400 guns most ended up in cape flats
where nearly 2 500 shootings have been
linked to illegal guns since 2010
including 261 child victims
[Music]
within the south african police
anti-corruption campaigners have
documented
over 475 reports of bribery
and over 300 reports of abuses of power
avril has founded a support group for
bereaved mothers
campaigning for justice in the face of
this corruption
thank you ladies for being here in the
past six years
229 dockets records of court proceedings
are reported to have gone missing in
western cape
leslie weingarte whose son was also
murdered in cape flats
says the files related to his case
mysteriously disappeared from the
courthouse
prosecutor told me but i had the file i
had the faster somebody sneaked
that file out of his office and made it
disappear
in south africa the rot of corruption
runs deep this secretly recorded footage
captured a successful businessman gavin
watson
seemingly organizing to pay bribes to
government officials
watson who died in 2019 was a hero of
the anti-apartheid struggle
and had close links to the anc party
which has been in power for 25 years
during the nine-year presidency of jacob
zuma
this corruption captured the state
right up to the very top
he and his cronies plundered state-owned
enterprises
in zuma's second term alone about a
hundred billion us dollars was stolen
just short of a third of south africa's
gdp
but south africans demanded change and
in 2019 they elected a new president on
an explicit platform to crack down on
corruption
cyril ramaphosa has set out to provide
the clean leadership that is vital
in any fight against corruption
we need to act with urgency and purpose
to restore
our state-owned enterprises
those who monitor the excesses of the
zoomy years are hopeful his successor
will drive
change from the top corruption watch has
been in existing space
years now mostly during the zuma
administration and working with the
two administrations is like night and
day
we now encounter an administration that
is much more willing to work with the
likes of us
doesn't mean that we don't have to be
vigilant in holding them to account
but it is there's definitely a new
spirit
a foot in the country although still
huge problems to overcome
the new leadership has already begun to
make its mark
i think it's achieved a fair amount in
the period
since ramaphosa was installed as
president
key zuma acolytes who were leaders of
critical institutions have been fired
others put in their place state-owned
enterprise boards have been
revamped
but fighting corruption on this scale
demands more than just
political leadership
commission chairperson deputy chief
justice raymond zondor announced
yesterday key appointments to his
commission
in 2018 judge raymond zondo
was appointed to head an unprecedented
commission of inquiry
into how corruption captured the state
under the zuma administration
we want to have an idea about the levels
of corruption in the country
and what forms corruption takes so that
we can make recommendations
as to what the country should do
to try and bring it up to the absolute
minimum
levels of corruption the commission has
heard
thousands of hours of testimony from
over a hundred witnesses to fraud and
corruption
zondo's warts and all approach to
exposing the problem
has been compared to the truth and
reconciliation commission
after the apartheid era above all it
educates the public it places before the
public
exactly what happened during the zuma
administration which as you can imagine
was subject to a lot of false news and
factual manipulation
with the truth now emerging there's also
a fresh push for justice
a new chief public prosecutor has
promised to clean up the national
prosecuting authority
another institution infiltrated by
zuma's cronies
all right okay good shamila batoyi is a
respected former lawyer from the
international criminal court in the
hague
and president ramaphosa's most
significant appointment to date
people know that it's not business as
usual
if we want to be serious about
addressing corruption we've got to make
sure that
there's strong committed ethical
leadership
in shamila batoy's new job that means
getting serious about enforcement
[Music]
we've got to look at prosecuting the
right people that is where
i think in the past the prosecution the
npa lost credibility
they failed to demonstrate that they
were
serious about tackling corruption and
that is not just within the npa but
certainly within the broader law
enforcement
space this kind of leadership
may start to convince south africans
that rhetoric has finally turned into
action
so i know that the people of south
africa are impatient understandably so
they have
every reason what is the greatest
deterrent to crime
the certainty that there will be an
investigation that there will be a
prosecution and there will be
consequences
and the sad reality is that in south
africa that wasn't the case in the
recent past
while clean leadership is vital to
tackling corruption
so is having the ability to spot it
in ukraine another country with a deep
history of corruption
the struggle for greater financial
transparency has been hard fought in
2014 a violent revolution deposed its
notoriously corrupt president
viktor yanukovych
during four years in office he and his
associates
stole an estimated 40 billion us dollars
from the public purse
activists who helped to depose
yanukovych have since traced the flows
of this stolen money
and helped to reveal the extent of his
corruption
one of them is
so we're in michigan as a in famous
mansion
that belonged to ex-president yankovic
yanukovych earned an official salary of
about a hundred thousand us dollars a
year
but he used the proceeds of corruption
to build this lavish palace
on 345 acres of land outside the capital
kiev
this is a huge territory with big houses
and golf courses and boxing rings and
restaurants
and his personal zoo with ostriches
it's a nice one he has nice eyebrows
kickbacks and bribes from government
contracts were one of the principal ways
of stealing money from the state
two billion dollars a year used to be
lost through government officials paying
over the odds for anything from building
materials
to medicines one of the reasons why
those in power could afford little
luxuries
such as a gold panel chapel limited
edition john lennon steinway piano
[Music]
and even toilet brushes encrusted with
swarovski crystals
everything here was built obviously
using
money siphoned from the budget so
basically
all this is like a museum to the
corruption
this kleptocracy was catastrophic for
ukrainians
denying them affordable health care and
good public services
after yanukovych was deposed max and
other activists set about changing the
system
that had allowed corruption to flourish
they determined that one thing in
particular would be
vital to transform ukraine
transparency specifically the ability to
trace and track the flows of public
money
the beauty of the system is that this is
just sort of like a website with
explanations and open data
this online system made the bidding
process for government contracts more
transparent now whenever government
officials want to buy something
they must put out a tender on a single
platform accessible to anyone
these are the ongoing tenders of the
kiev region there are
just over 10 000 ongoing tenders right
now
verse 1.8 billion euro
and these are the statuses of procedures
and so on and so on
roughly a million tenders go through the
system each year
and the system must openly log every bid
for every government contract
as a combination of better usability
compulsory auctions and
different mechanisms to fight collusion
and price fixing and different types of
fraud
we're able to save about seven to eight
percent
of for the value of each tender it's
estimated that the system known as pro
zorro
has contributed to reducing the cost of
corruption to ukraine
by six billion us dollars per year since
2014
and the system is now being used in
other countries
i'm actually proud that our country
changed its positioning from being one
of the worst
places for public procurement in the
world to one of the obvious
technological
leaders and pioneers in this area
but whilst greater transparency has
helped ukraine to discover and expose
corruption
the country still lacks a vital tool to
tackle it
effective enforcement authorities to
hold the guilty parties accountable
more than 11 million documents they
reveal what's alleged to be
a global network of tax avoidance
evasion
and money laundering when the most
ruthless of the mexican drug cartels
wanted to hide their money
they went to hsbc
[Music]
in today's globalized world enforcement
agencies in wealthy countries face a
challenge to root out corruption and
deliver justice
and they're increasingly deploying new
technologies to help
so the investigation covered three
decades across
three business sectors and seven
different jurisdictions this was one of
the largest cases the sfo had worked on
in 2013 the serious fraud office in
london
began investigating systematic bribery
by one of britain's most prestigious
companies
rolls royce
[Music]
five years into their investigation the
sfo
had gathered 30 million documents and
needed to determine
which could be used to prosecute the
firm
we started reviewing it using the the
old method which was just to use keyword
searches and then
instruct independent barristers to
review that material and we needed to
find a way to speed that up
advances in technology meant that ai and
machine learning
based products became available that
could help with this work
in the first use of ai in a british
criminal case
the system was able to search documents
2 000 times faster than human lawyers
and more reliably
[Music]
and what this tool does is looks for
patterns within the documents patterns
in communication
and what we were able to find was the
results were more consistent
and that's not to say that the lawyers
were making mistakes but the reality is
if you have five different lawyers
they will make different determinations
[Music]
in court rolls-royce admitted that in
six countries across the world
middlemen had paid tens of millions of
dollars in bribes
in order to secure contracts for the
company
aware that the punishment faced by rolls
royce could act as a useful deterrent to
other companies
the british authorities ordered the firm
to pay a record fine of around 650
million dollars
in return for avoiding prosecution
[Music]
critics say that individual prosecutions
rather than just a huge
fine would act as a clearer deterrent to
future wrongdoing
but the serious fraud office insists
that money talks
a settlement of this size will
absolutely act as a disincentive against
corruption
particularly in a case like rollerboys
where not only does it have that
financial impact immediately
but there are certain conditions which
they must meet in terms of their systems
and processes and how they have to
operate in the future
to demonstrate to the court uh that they
are not
uh continuing with this sort of behavior
rolls-royce says it has made a raft of
changes
strengthening its compliance and
oversight procedures
and introducing new technology
we now have an app a code of conduct app
rather than a written document
that means that everybody on their
iphone has access to
support both in respect of the policies
and the processes but know who to speak
to if they need
help the company insists its actions
have brought about a culture change
which will make corrupt behavior less
likely in the future
i can tell you that the exercise we have
been through at rolls-royce
has not been box ticking we provided
super cooperation
in respect of fixing the past issues we
have taken incredibly seriously and
frankly spent a lot of money
dealing with both the past and trying to
set up the framework for the future
but none of this would have happened had
rolls-royce not been caught all too
often companies efforts to educate staff
about avoiding fraud are motivated by
the demands of compliance regulations
rather than a genuine desire to change
the culture around corruption
doing that requires a new attitude to
the men and women
who lift the lid on corruption in the
first place
cynthia stimpell was group treasurer at
south african airways
a state-owned enterprise in 2016
she discovered that the company was
apparently planning to avoid due
diligence procedures
cynthia was asked to raise money to
finance debts
by paying a new company substantially
over the amount charged by banks
i then said well i'm not prepared to
sign it i'm not prepared to approve it
we should go back to the banks let's get
a different costing
and i'm sure we will save money but it
went ahead and it was approved by board
despite my refusal to sign the documents
cynthia blew the whistle on this highly
irregular transaction
well at the time was firstly a
determination that i need to do this
and that it's the right thing to do for
my own personal conscious
for my personal values for my own moral
compass
my name is cynthia agnes suraya
when she testified at the zondo
commission into corruption
cynthia hit the public eye as her
actions had helped save taxpayers
17 million dollars but south african
airways wasn't so grateful
cynthia lost her job she has since
joined forces with other whistleblowers
who have suffered similar fates their
message is clear
if companies are serious about
installing an ethical culture
they need to reward whistleblowers not
punish them
most of the people here held senior
positions at major companies
all alleged fraud at those companies yet
all ended up losing their jobs for
blowing the whistle
i thought i would be protected because i
followed
everything to the tea but what the first
thing that happened i was called in
and immediately suspended without even
being able to speak i wasn't able to
give my
side of the story i still haven't had a
hearing
the end result is that i've lost my job
without whistleblowers we wouldn't have
zondo commission
everybody asked but why people not
speaking up but if you look at all the
people that's gone to all these
commissions
all of them have lost their jobs so what
does that teach you
don't speak up because you'll lose your
job
the culturing companies may be slow to
change
but the increased visibility of
whistleblowers is helping drive a
broader shift in south africa's
collective will to challenge corruption
do we accept the way it is or do you
stand up for something
i think the people around this table
decided to stand up for something
we've got some of the key change makers
that the globe has ever seen in our
history
we have that fortitude the resilience we
want to better south africa
[Music]
this determination of the few to make a
stand is a vital step to tackling
corruption
but it doesn't happen in a vacuum
seeing corrupt individuals or companies
held to account
may encourage others to think twice
new tools make it easier to expose
wrongdoing in the first place
and together they feed the momentum for
change
from the public from business and from
those in power
that's the key to disrupting corruption
you